tell me if the gender advisory the
gender equality advisory council will be
working to
improve women and girls participation in
stem education and industries
well i'm pleased to say that the giac is
packed with inspirational
stem leaders such as professor sarah
gilbert who spearheaded the oxford
vaccine
and the cern director general dr fabio
lee giannato
these are leading figures and a key aim
of the g-ac
is to make sure that more girls and
women are involved in those industries
of the future like technology and
science
so they can get those well-paid jobs but
also help
drive forward progress across the world
thank you mr speaker at the g7 summit in
august 2000
2019 the government made three
commitments for domestic progress on
gender equality
delivery of the domestic abuse bill
reform of parental leave and action on
workplace sexual
harassment but last year just 3.5
percent of fathers
took shared parental leave and the tuc
found that one in two women experienced
sexual harassment at work
and we are still waiting for the
government to respond to consultations
on both
of these issues so what does the
minister think it says about her record
that only
one of those commitments have so far
been completed
and when will she bring forward reforms
to these skills
secretary as she points out we have
brought forward
and have enacted a leading uh domestic
abuse bill and my uh
honorable friend uh the minister for
safeguarding is on the front bench and
she's done a fantastic job on that
we will shortly be bringing forward the
response on sexual harassment
and moreover i want to make sure that at
this year's g7
leaders across the world are held to
account on their record
in protecting women and girls joy
anderson
mr speaker
the uk is using our presidency of the g7
this year to champion women's
and girls rights at home and around the
world with an independent gender
equality advisory council
to bring fresh ideas and new voices to
the heart of g7 discussions
the council met for the second time last
week and i look forward to hearing their
recommendations
to g7 leaders in june it's important
that women and girls are at the heart
of our plans to build back better
thank you mr speaker in the recent
queen's speech there were many
opportunities to level up across the
country
including my great constituency of
wolverhampton south west
what is my right honourable friend doing
to see that we can
unleash the potential of some of our
more deprived areas
to build back better after covid
well we are determined to tackle the
scourge of geographical inequality
that's why we have taken on
responsibility for the social mobility
commission
they are going to focus on the three e's
employment education and enterprise
and we're currently recruiting a chair
to spearhead this agenda
okay thank you mr speaker can the
secretary of state tell me how she will
ensure that the voices
of survivors of so-called conversion
therapy
and the people who support them will be
heard in the consultation
in bringing about a bill to outlaw all
conversion practices
because conversion therapies have no
place in all settings
and all lgbt plus statuses regardless of
whether someone is consenting
or coerced well my friend the
minister for equality has already met
survivors of conversion therapy and
we're determined that they should be
closely involved
in the consultation we're holding on the
forthcoming legislation i completely
agree with her
this is an aborig practice that we need
to stop in the united kingdom
jacob young thank you mr speaker in
redcor and cleveland and across the
country the pandemic
has left many people without the
certainty of work but in particular
those disabled and differently abled
people who already feel disadvantaged in
the jobs market
we've announced an ambitious plan for
jobs but can the minister point to
specific interventions he is making
to help more disabled people into work
in regular cleveland and the wider
thieves valley
well mr speaker there's been an 800
increase in disability confident
employers in the durham tees valley area
and i know that the newly re-elected
conservative tees valley mayor
ben houchen and our new hartlepool mp
are utterly committed to ensure more
disabled people get into work
and use access to work to assist that
let's go to angela crawley
angela thank you mr speaker
in the uk two weeks parental leave and
pay is in place after stillbirth
however there is no such support for
anyone who's experienced a miscarriage
before 24 weeks of pregnancy
will the ministers support my calls to
the uk government
and allow families to grieve for their
profound loss
by legislating for paid leave for
everyone that experiences miscarriage
i'm grateful for the honourable lady for
raising this point and uh we we have um
looked at uh and are seeking to change
the rules around
neo-natal leave clearly and any grieving
situation is incredibly difficult
but we will work with uh as we work
towards the employment bill to make sure
that we can come up with a rounded view
for for anybody that is grieving
let's go to chris england chrisman
um uh mr speaker my right honourable
friend yesterday
at the uh select committee said she
ended the role of her
lgbt advisory panel because of a basic
disagreement over the right of trans
people to self
id argentina our co-chair of the equal
rights coalition
whose conference we host next june
legally accommodated self-id for trans
people since 2012 without a problem
as are now more members of the coalition
following argentina's example without a
problem
how is she going to find a new panel
that has both authority
and agrees with her in the continuing
refusal
to accept the right of trans people to
self-id
and can she explain how britain can host
a conference entitled
safe to be me without supporting the
right to be me
uh i thank the honorable gentleman for
that question the former lgbt advisory
panel's tenure ended on the 31st of
march 2021
i am grateful to its members for their
important insights and
they've provided that that they've
provided on important policy areas such
as ending
conversion therapy and the impact of
curvid on lgbt people
the pm has appointed lord herbert a
special envoy for lgbt rights
this role will have an international and
domestic focus and i am confident
that we will be able to work with our
international partners um
on this issue we believe the current
provisions within the act allow for
those who wish to legally change their
gender to do so
it is safe to be them and they do have
the right to be themselves
and we've therefore decided as we've
said before to the honourable gentleman
that the gender recognition act will not
be changed
let's go to jeff smith jeff
speaker my constituent julia was
breastfeeding her child in a park when a
stranger started taking long glenn's
photos of her
and she and i were shocked that there
was nothing that could be done about
this unwelcome
intrusion does the minister think this
is an acceptable situation
and if not would you support action to
prevent this kind of voyeurism
i thank the normal member for raising
this very very important topic
of course this is totally unacceptable
behavior
and i hope he will welcome the
government's forthcoming violence
against women and girls strategy that
will be
publishing later this year drawing in
the views of more than 180
000 members of the public uh to help
shape our policies
for the coming decade this is
unacceptable and we will deal with it
all that that ends the questions we're
now going to go to
questions the prime minister with which
i will first call the prime minister to
answer the engagement question
and then i will then call dan poulter to
ask his supplementary virtually
prime minister boris johnson mr speaker
the thoughts of the house
will be with the family and friends of
the hillsborough 96
and the hundreds more who are injured
following the decision by the court this
morning
i know that the cps has said they will
meet with the families again to answer
any questions
they may have mr speaker i know
colleagues from across the house will
want to join me in paying tribute
to our former colleague mike weatherly
who sadly died
last week he was a dedicated
parliamentarian and a fantastic servant
to the people of hove mr speaker this
morning i had meetings with ministerial
colleagues
and others in addition to my duties in
this house i shall have further such
meetings
later today let's go to dr dan poulter
down
thank you mr speaker i draw the house's
attention to my declaration of members
interests
as a practicing nhs doctor who's been
working on the front line
of the nhs during the pandemic now my
right honourable friend will be aware
the 2012 health and social care act
resulted in local authority
commissioning of addiction services
and 10 years later all addiction almost
all addiction services are now run
by non-nhs providers the result is that
the numbers in alcohol treatment have
fallen
many alcohol detoxes take place in an
unplanned manner and both opiate and
alcohol deaths
at record levels would my right
honourable friend agree with me that for
the sake of patience we must bring
commissioning and provision of addiction
services back to the nhs
and will he meet with me and experts in
this field to discuss how we can get
this right
mr speaker i want to thank my honourable
friend for everything that he's done
throughout this pandemic
in the nhs but also for raising this
vital issue
and of course i'm proud that we're
seeing the biggest increase under this
government in
treatment for substance abuse for 15
years
but the specific points he raises we
will make sure that we address
uh with dr dame carol black who is
undertaking a review
on drugs and treatment and uh we'll make
sure that his point
is fed in let's go to the leader of the
opposition
kia stammer thank you mr speaker can i
join the prime minister in his comments
about hillsboro and mike weatherby
mr speaker this morning the prime
minister's former closest adviser said
when the public needed us most the
government failed
does the prime minister agree with that
uh mr speaker the handling of this
pandemic has been one of the
most difficult things this country's had
to do for a very long time and none of
the decisions
have been easy to go into a lockdown is
a traumatic thing for a country to deal
with a pandemic on this scale
has been appallingly difficult and we've
at every stage
uh tried to minimize loss of life to
save lives to protect the nhs
and we've followed the best scientific
advice that we that we can mr speaker
to speak can i remind the prime minister
that one year ago almost
to the day he described his former
advisor as
in his words in every respect acting
responsibly
legally and with integrity
this morning that same advisor has said
that senior ministers fell
his words disastrously short of the
standards
that the public has a right to expect of
its government
and that lies were lost as a result
does the prime minister accept that
central allegation and that his act
in action led to needless deaths
no mr speaker and of course all those
matters will be
uh reviewed in the in the course of uh
the public inquiry that i have
announced i noticed that he's fixated as
ever on the
on the rear view mirror uh mr speaker uh
whilst we uh on this side of the house
are getting on uh with our job of
rolling out the vaccines
uh making sure that we protect the
people of this country and that i think
has been
uh the decisive uh development on which
i think people are rightly
focusing and i can tell the house that
in spite of
the continuing concern that we have
about the uh the indian variant uh
we are increasing our vaccination
program at such a rate that we can now
ask everybody over 30 to come forward
mr speaker and get vaccinated
speaker there's no good the prime
minister attacking me
it's his former chief it's his former
chief adviser
who's looking back and telling the world
how useless the prime minister was in
taking key decisions
his former advisor one of the most
serious points made this morning
is that the prime minister failed to
recognize the severity of this virus
until it was too late dismissing it as
quote from this morning
another scare story like the swine flu
does the prime minister recognize that
account of his own behavior
and if so will he apologize for being so
complacent about the threat that this
virus posed
mr speaker i don't think anybody could
credibly accuse this government of being
complacent about the threat that this
virus posed at any at any point
we have worked flat out mr speaker to
minimize
loss of life to protect the nhs while
they have flip-flopped mr speaker from
one
position to another uh backing curfew
one day
opposing at the next backing knockdowns
one day opposing the next calling for
tougher border controls one day
uh then saying that quarantine is a
blunt instrument mr speaker
we have got on with the job of
protecting the people of this country
from one of the worst pandemics in
living memory if not the worst
in living back no memory we have turned
the corner and it is
no thanks mr speaker to the loyal
opposition
[Applause]
mr opposite i can see that the evidence
of his former advisor is really getting
to the prime minister
this morning in that response another
incredibly serious statement from the
prime minister's former advisor this
morning
concerns the conduct of the health
secretary
including an allegation that the health
secretary misled other ministers and
officials
on a number of occasions now i don't
expect the prime minister to respond
to that but can he confirm from this
morning's evidence
can the prime minister can he confirm
did the cabinet secretary
advise him the prime minister that he
the cabinet secretary had quote
lost faith in the health secretary's
honesty
the answer to that is no mr speaker and
i'm afraid i haven't had the benefits of
uh of seeing the evidence that he uh
that he's bringing to the to the house
but i
i must say that i think what the people
of this country want us
all to do is to get on uh with the
delicate business
now of trying to reopen our economy
and restore people's uh restore people's
freedoms
get back to our way of life by rolling
out the vaccine
i would have thought that that was a a
much more profitable line
of inquiry for the right honourable
gentleman today and that's what i think
the people of this country
want us to focus on speaker the prime
minister can't have it
both ways either his former adviser
is telling the truth in which case the
prime minister should answer the
allegations
or the prime minister has to suggest
that his former adviser is not telling
the truth
which raises serious questions about the
prime minister's judgment in appointing
him in the first place
there's a pattern of behavior here there
was clearly a lack of planning
poor decision making and a lack of
transparency and a prime minister who
was absent from the key decisions
including five early cobra meetings and
who was to quote his former adviser
a thousand percent too obsessed with the
media
but another central allegation briefed
overnight
is that the prime minister delayed the
circuit break over the autumn half term
because quotes covid was only killing
80 year olds can i remind the prime
minister that over 83
000 people over 80 lost their lives to
this virus
and that his decision to delay for 40
days
from the sage guidance on the 21st of
september
until the 31st of october will be seen
as one of the single biggest failings
of the last year does the
now having been told of the evidence
does the prime minister accept
that he used the words kovid was only
killing
80 year olds or words to those effect
prime minister mr speaker uh we
we saw what happened uh during the
the pandemic and particularly he talks
about the uh the september
lockdown and my approach to it and the
uh
the the very very difficult decision
that the country faced and
uh of course this would be a matter for
the inquiry to uh to go into but we have
a
an objective test mr speaker in this in
the sense that
there was a circuit breaker of the kind
he describes in wales uh it did not work
and uh and i'm afraid to speak i'm
absolutely confident
that we took the decisions in the best
interests of the
of the british people it and uh when it
comes to
when it comes to hindsight mr speaker i
could just just remind the right
honourable gentleman that he actually
i mean he denied this at the time but
and then had to correct it but he voted
to stay in the european medicines agency
mr speaker
which would have made it impossible
which would have made it impossible for
us to do
the vaccine rollout at the pace that we
have
[Music]
mr speaker it's not me giving evidence
this morning it's his former
advisor and i note the prime minister's
careful not to refute these
allegations mr speaker what we're seeing
today is the latest
chapter of a story of confusion chaos
and deadly misjudgments from this
government
from a prime minister governing by press
release not a plan
in the last 24 hours we've seen the same
mistakes made
again with the ridiculous way 1.7
million people in bolton
burnley bedford blackburn kirklees
hounslow leicester and north tyneside
have been treated in the light of the
drip of these very serious allegations
and the failure of the prime minister to
provide even basic answers
and continuing mistakes affecting
millions of people does the prime
minister now recognize he must bring
forward the timing of the public inquiry
into covet
and that should start this summer and as
soon as possible
no mr speaker as i've said before i'm
not going to consecrate valuable
official time on that
now uh whilst we're still battling a
pandemic and i thought actually that was
what the house
had agreed on and mr speaker he
continues to play these pointless
uh political games uh whilst we get on
with delivering on
the people's priorities 40 new hospitals
8
71 more police on our streets now we're
getting on with sorting out the railways
uh mr speaker we're giving the people
the young people the opportunity of home
ownership in a way they've never had
before with 95
more mortgages and we vaccinated we've
done we've delivered 60 million
vaccinations across this country more
and he loves these european comparisons
mr speaker more than any other
european country including 22 million
second doses and
that with great respect to the
right-oriented i believe
that is the priority of the british
people that's really
uh what they're focused on whilst he
voted to stay
in the european medicines agency they
vacillate mr speaker we vaccinate
they they deliberate we deliver
tom two gundam thank you mr speaker i'm
sure my right old friend the prime
minister
remembers with great fondness his trip
of july last year to the discovery
school
in kings hill but he would probably
remember his best his meeting with tony
hudgell an amazing and inspirational
young boy who had at that point already
raised a million and a half pounds for
charity and been awarded
by my right honourable friend the points
of light award that he so generously
hands out to those who've achieved so
much
will he join tony and tony's parents
paula and mark and
me and many others around the country
and campaigning for tony's law
new clause 56 to the policing crime and
sentencing bill
this is a very minor change to a very
important bill that would bring
child abuse sentencing in line with that
of adult abuse i know he
has put his heart into this space and
i'm sure
we can all look forward to his support
i'm minister i i thank
my honorable friend of course i remember
uh tony very
well and i remember uh his incredible
campaign and the amount of money he
raised and i thank him
uh for it and uh i all i can say is it
is very very important that
uh cases like that uh injustices such as
that suffered by tony do receive the
full force
of the law and uh it is
people who commit serious offenses
against children can receive exactly the
same penalties
as those who commit serious offences
against adults but we will keep this
under review
uh mr speaker and if there is a gap in
the law i will study here very closely
if there is a gap in the law we will
make sure that we remedy it
leader of the smp in blackfoot thank you
mr speaker can i associate myself with
the remarks of prime minister for
those seeking justice for hillsborough
to quote the song you'll never walk
alone
mr speaker 128 000 people have died of
coronavirus
in the united kingdom this morning
the prime minister's most senior former
advisor dominic cummings
apologized on behalf of the uk
government he said
when the public needed us most we failed
we know that the prime minister made a
series of catastrophic errors throughout
the crisis
he went on holiday when he should have
been leading efforts to tackle the
pandemic
he was too slow to go into lockdown he
failed
to secure our borders he sent millions
of people
back to their offices prematurely there
is no doubt
that these mistakes cost many thousands
of lives
when even a disgraced figure like
dominic cummings is willing to own up
and apologize isn't it time that the
prime minister
does the same yesterday and mr speaker i
take full responsibility for
everything that has happened i'm and
i've said as i've said uh before and he
will recall
uh both in this house and elsewhere i am
truly sorry for the suffering that
the people of this country uh have
experienced but i
maintain uh my point that the government
acted throughout
uh with the intention to save life and
protect the
nhs and in accordance with the best
scientific advice that's exactly what we
do
in blackfoot thank you mr speaker the
evidence
we've heard this morning is
extraordinary but sadly not surprising
it paints a familiar pattern of
a negligent prime minister more
concerned with his own self-interest
than the interests of the united kingdom
when people were dying the united
kingdom government
was considering chicken pox parties
and joking about injecting the prime
minister with covert live on tv
we had a circus act when we needed
serious government
isn't it the case that what the country
needed leadership most
the prime minister was missing in action
thousands have paid
the ultimate price for his failure when
will the
prime minister finally accept
responsibility
for the failures of his government
[Music]
mr speaker i said repeatedly in the
entire side take full responsibility
for everything that the government did
and
uh will continue to do so and one of the
reasons we've set up an independent
public inquiry so i believe the people
this country
do deserve to have uh daylight shone on
all the
issues he raised i must say i don't uh
recognize the events that he
uh that he describes uh but i do think
that
we acted throughout uh with the
intention of
of saving life uh of protecting the nhs
and of taking the country through the
worst pandemic for a hundred years
and i think if you if i think it's also
true uh that we're in a much more
fortunate position now thanks to the
efforts of the british people
and the fastest vaccine roll out in
in europe and i'm i'm grateful for that
as well
mr speaker i spent monday morning at the
fitz country house in cottonwood with an
alpaca called boris
cumbria sees significant numbers of
tourists in any normal year
becoming is not just lakes we have some
real gems in my constituency of
workington
outside the national park with a real
opportunity for the uk this year
for the uk hospitality industry this
year as people choose to holiday here
would my right honourable friend
consider a short break in my
constituency
where i might facilitate an introduction
to boris
well i'm so i'm so grateful to my
honorable friend i would love to come
and meet
the al parker uh called boris
um and but more importantly uh we want
to support
the tourism in his constituency which is
why we so far provided over 25 billion
of support
including 1.5 million to support
projects such as the carnegie
theater trust and since this week is
english tourism week mr speaker
i encourage everyone to make the most of
the tourism on their doorstep
go to stephen ferry stephen thank you mr
speaker the eu settlement scheme
closes on the 30th of june while the
home office has finally published
guidance on net applications
the government is failing to provide
clarity what will happen to those who
miss the deadline
and then fall under the remit of illegal
working legislation
so can the prime minister assure the
house that eu citizens
or non-au family members who miss the
deadline will not
face potential criminal liability if
they continue to go into work
uh mr speaker i'm sure that the law will
be extremely merciful to
anybody who finds themselves in a
difficult position but i would just
remind
uh the honorable gentleman uh that so
far uh
5.4 million uh eu nationals have applied
successfully for the eu
settlement scheme which is about as far
as i can about two million more uh eu
nationals than we thought were in the
country in the first place
thank you mr speaker with the prime
minister join with me in praising
wrexham and dembesher councils
for the dynamic proposals that they are
putting forward in their joint bid
for the leveling up fund include south
including regeneration of the trevor
basin
improvements for church and clan
gothelin an investment in corwin station
and the surrounding area
can i tell my honourable friend what a
joy it is to hear him campaigning for
uh the for church and and corwin and
clan gotham after i
i i tramped around those beautiful
places entirely fruitlessly
uh many many years ago in search of the
conservative vote uh thank you for what
you
you've done uh thank you for continuing
uh to champion
uh those wonderful wonderful and
beautiful spots
gerald jones thank you mr speaker when
any member of this house is suspended
for 10 days or more
because of a standards committee report
constituents can then recall that member
when the independent expert panel
suspender member this can't happen
the the prime minister a moment ago was
talking about closing loopholes in
legislation so
will the prime minister introduce
emergency legislation to close this
particular loophole
and does he agree that it would be
completely dishonorable for any member
to exploit that loophole and should
instead do the decent thing
and resign
mr speaker i will i will take that i
take that point very sincerely i will i
will i will study what uh
the implications of what he says i think
if he's referring uh to any
uh a conservative member who's uh who's
recently
uh had the whip uh taken away then he
can take it that that member who's
already had
uh condemned punishment governor
fletcher
thank you mr speaker and last thursday
through about one o'clock in the morning
three young people popped out to mackie
d's
as you do um they noticed a leyland shop
massively on fire and did they drive
past no
they rang the fire brigade they stopped
they recruited a passerby
they climbed over fences and walls to
raise the alarm for the residents living
in the flats above them
now during the pandemic community spirit
has been really important to all of us
keeping going
so does the prime minister share my
admiration for kim
zach shania and robin and will he join
me in thanking them for showing british
community spirit
and true lancashire grit yeah yes
mr speaker i thank my honourable friend
for singling out this act of
uh this intrepid act of quick thinking
and selflessness and i pay tribute to
kim
zach shania and robin and i hope that
they
they got their mackie ds
there are over 4.3 million children mr
speaker
and rising growing up in poverty
including some 18
000 in harrow so will he agree to put
right the error of a previous prime
minister
and commit to publish a strategy to
tackle child poverty
and ensure that no child is left behind
mr speaker it's vital that we tackle
child poverty and that's why
we are uh uniting and leveling up across
the country with the biggest program of
investment
uh for for a generation if not
more but we've also we're also seeing
fewer households
uh now with children in poverty than 10
years ago
but i i perfectly accept that there is
more to be done
thank you mr speaker i very much welcome
the fact that government is investing
heavily in upgrading the rail networks
across the country including opening
lines that have previously been
closed but as a conservative government
we've got a particular responsibility to
the taxpayer to ensure value for money
east west rail and my constituency's
business case is largely based on
commuting but the pandemic means we're
in the middle of a workplace
revolution if people work from home on
average two days a week in future that
means a 40
reduction in commuting will my right
honourable friend the prime minister
commit to doing a review of the business
place of east-west rail
to ensure it remains value for money and
to take into account the long-term
impact of the pandemic
mr speaker i i fully i i think my honor
is a great campaigner for
for cambridgeshire and and the right to
people character however my
strong feeling is it would be a mistake
now to go slow
on investment in infrastructure purely
on the basis that we think people will
start
uh working uh from home uh my long
experience of this is that people
need to travel they will travel the
commuter bustle
will come back mr speaker and it needs
to come back
thank you mr speaker a global minimum
rate for corporate corporate tax
would help tackle tax avoidance by large
multinational corporations and online
giants it would stop them undercutting
british businesses who pay their fair
share
and it would make a transformational
difference to high streets and town
centres
at the heart of communities across the
uk
why is the prime minister the only g7
leader
not to support this proposal why is he
on the side of tax avoiders
instead of british businesses and
communities
mr speaker it was only a few months ago
that the uh
the labor party labor front bench
opposed the corporation tax increases
uh that we put in uh they're now opposed
to uh the government's ability to cut
corporation debts which side are they on
they've got to make their minds up
let's go to sir robert neal robert
thank you mr speaker like me the prime
minister represents the constituency in
london's commuter land
so he'll be well aware of the small
businesses sole traders many of them
who operate the coffee stores and news
agents and so on
on our railway stations their incomes
have been absolutely decimated
during the pandemic but they're finding
like my constituent sanjay
sharma at chisel her station that when
they seek to get a reduced level of rent
to reflect their reduced turnover
the trade operating companies claim that
a funding agreement put in place with
the department
of transport doesn't give them the
discretion to do so the department
appears to say differently and they've
been going around in months
in circles for months trying to get an
answer will the prime minister use the
authority of his office please
to bang heads together and get a
solution for them because if they go
broke
and we have empty units that's no income
for anybody
uh mr speaker i thank my right
honourable friend we've provided
uh we've put in introduced policy to
provide rent relief uh for
uh station businesses in march of last
year
all train operators including
southeastern in his constituency
are able to offer uh business support to
their to their stations i understand the
point he makes about
uh the discrepancy of views uh can i
undertake tim
uh to arrange a meeting uh with him and
the relevant
minister to take it forward let's go to
rachel maskel
rachel thank you mr speaker
i have asked the prime minister a series
of questions about charities
in november he promised support by march
he turned his back
but this month he broke that promise
giving them nothing this winter
his words and deeds as unfaithful as his
principles and beliefs
is neither the commitment to honor his
word the capacity to care
nor the compassion to act does the prime
minister really believe that charity
is all about supporting him and his
lifestyle or recognized charities now 10
billion in debt and struggling to
survive need government support to help
people in real need
prime minister mr speaker i think
charities perform
uh an amazing and invaluable role in our
society and our and in our lives and we
need them and
that's why we've supported uh charity
shops throughout
uh the the lockdown with grants with
restart grants
and the roadmap means that the shops are
now able to
to open again but in addition uh we had
a 750 million pound targeted
package of support for charities helping
more than 14 thousand
organizations across the country uh
including funding for
hospices homelessness charity charities
and shelters for
uh for the victims of domestic abuse and
many others mr speaker
petrol thank you very much mr speaker
the fishing industry in east anglia has
had a hard time of it in recent years
however with brexit done albeit in a way
that left many disappointed
there is now an opportunity to turn the
corner the reef that's the rene source
of east anglian fisheries strategy sets
out an exciting and ambitious programme
for the future
is the prime minister able to say how
the government will work with fishing
communities such as that in lost
to revive the industry in east anglia
yeah
yes mr speaker i thank my honourable
friend for what he's doing to champion
the fisheries
uh industry in east anglia i like his
riaf
his reef uh plan i think it's got lots
of
interesting ideas which we will take
forward as part of our 100 million pound
package
and support the fishing industry and get
ready to take advantage of those
opportunities which are coming very very
swiftly uh down the track towards us
bentley the officer speaker nhs and
social care staff in wales are due to
receive a
500 pound bonus in recognition of their
hard work during the pandemic
but staff on universal credit stand to
lose out due to the way in which the
reward is recognized in regulations as
earned income
so instead of receiving a thank you
bonus at the end of the month many nhs
and social case staff will be punished
with a deduction of up to 63 percent to
the universal credit
will the prime minister look to amend
regulation 55 of universal credit
regulations
to create an exemption to ensure that
all nhs and social care staff in wales
benefit fully from this well-deserved
bonus yeah
i'm grateful to him for the for raising
that point and uh of course
i want to repeat my my gratitude to the
nurses of this country
the nhs and social care staff who who've
done incredible work throughout this uh
this pandemic he makes a particular
point about the end of
the uc the taper in uh in universal
credit and i will make sure
that he has a meeting with the relevant
uh minister uh who will set out
the detail on the issue he's raised
let's go to jonathan lord
jonathan thank you mr speaker
on behalf of my constituents seema misra
and other wrongly convicted
subpostmasters i'm grateful that the
vital inquiry of sir william williams
into this scandal
has now been given more teeth however
there is widespread concern shared by
post office ceo
nick reed that the compensation received
by the subpostmasters
who were party to the civil litigation
at the high court
was simply not fair can i urge the prime
minister to ensure
that these civil litigant subpostmasters
will be included
in the anticipated government
compensation scheme
prime minister i thank you for raising
this this this issue
i might say a tragic uh case of of
injustice and i've
met some of the post office uh the
postmasters and subpost masters who've
been
affected by uh this miscarriage of
justice
as he knows uh the the government wasn't
party to the
uh initial uh litigation nor the the
settlement
uh that was agreed but we are determined
to ensure that
postmaster subpost masters are fairly
compensated for what happened
[Applause]
thanks brendan mcneil
mr speaker brexit and scottish
independence indeed very different but
referendums are much the same
now in 2016 uh without interference the
european union respected the uk in the
brexit referendum process
unfortunately the last scottish
referendum did not see scotland at the
same respect
london politicians promised scotland
their place in the european union
clearly they won that referendum very
clearly
on broken promises in the order when the
scots government has dealt with the
health effects of the pandemic the
economic party will require independence
as norway and ireland prove
so prime minister will scotland be shown
the same respect in the uk
as the uk got in the eu and this time
can our democracy not be interfered with
on a referendum certainly not blocked
prime minister mr speaker we we
respected the
referendum result of 2014 uh which was
which was uh a very substantial majority
in favor of
uh remaining in the uk uh keeping our
wonderful country together not breaking
it up uh that was what the people
of scotland uh rightly voted for uh and
then they did so
uh in the belief that it was a once in a
generation event
the chickens thank you mr speaker for
almost 500 years the royal navy has
protected our country from foes and of
the freedom of our friends around the
world
the pride of our navy hms queen of
livers elizabeth sailed this week with
her strike group
within her she carries the british
values of freedom justice and democracy
so can i write on my friend tell me she
makes her way from the mediterranean to
the south
china sea what are his plans for the
future of her white ensign
prime minister it was fantastic to be
aboard hms queen elizabeth which is a
a vessel longer than the palace of
westminster uh itself
uh mr speaker and and uh uh forms a more
eloquent statement
in many ways in many of the speak many
speeches or indeed interventions uh that
we've heard
uh this afternoon about uh britain's
role in the world
and uh on our determination to expand
shipbuilding uh and expand our naval
presence which not only
uh is good for uh the uk and good for
the world but good for
jobs uh and growth around the country
thank you mr speaker kovid has now
triggered the first
global rise in extreme poverty this
century
but at the g7 the prime minister could
act
he can ask leaders to re-allocate the
imf's one trillion dollars worth of
special drawing rights
and restock the world bank's 83 billion
pounds worth
of iba fund this is a multi-billion
pound package of support
for the world's poorest so will the
prime minister stay commit
to leading this argument at the g7 so a
pandemic of disease
doesn't now become a pandemic of poverty
prime minister i thank him for it it's
great to see him in his place
i say mr speaker uh uh
and actually uh i i i've already i've
already had uh always write to you this
place i i i've had conversations on that
very matter already with uh with
christina georgieva
one of the many awful things about the
past year has been the inability to
visit
family and friends in hospital it's
caused immense anguish for many of my
constituents
we're seeing some progress locally and i
hope with the brilliant roll out of the
vaccine we will see more
but can the prime minister inform the
house when we will see normal visiting
hours resumed for all hospitals
nationwide mister i know she speaks for
many many millions of people who have
uh who have wanted to visit loved ones
mr speaker and
uh i know the anguish that they have uh
that they have felt
uh and we need to balance that those
feelings which are wholly legitimate and
right with the need to
to manage the risk of uh of infection as
i know she understands very well
and will be up updating the guidance as
soon as it's possible to do so
thank you mr speaker tala 13 ruler just
five years old
her big sister yara aged nine three
palestinian children killed in an
israeli airstrike
the israeli military murdered 63 other
children and 245 palestinians
in its recent assault on gaza the call
for palestinian freedom has never been
louder but this conservative government
is complicit
in its denial it has approved more than
400 million pounds in arms
to israel since 2015. so can the prime
minister
look me in the eye and tell me that
british made weapons or components
weren't used in the war crimes that
killed these three children
and hundreds of other palestinians
prime minister we shouldn't use props
just to remind members
mr speaker i think that the whole house
understands
that nobody wants to see
any more of the conflict of the
appalling conflict that we've seen
in israel and and gaza and everybody
wants to i think
we're all glad that there's now a
ceasefire and a de-escalation
and as for the position of the british
government i think that it's probably
common ground across most members of
this house
the the what we want to see is a two
state
solution and mr speaker that is that is
what the uk government has campaigned
for
for many many years and that continues
to be our position
i'm now suspending the house for three
minutes to enable necessary raises to be
made for the next business order
you